[Musique]
c'est l'adieu à la lune déjà 40 mois
seulement après la demie triomphale
d'apollo 11
les américains abandonnent leur conquête
peut être jusqu'à la fin du siècle
l'astronautique américaine a pourtant
surmonter l'épreuve poste apollo unique
l'enthousiasmé était vraiment
fantastique et
c'était très
fait intéressant par exemple nous avions
des astronautes qui venions ici que dès
qu'ils venaient ici de temps en temps et
ils nous donnaient beaucoup de conseils
il voulait les commandes ici ils
voulaient ceci changer cela comme ça et
ainsi de suite
enfin vous vous être réadapté à
l'aviation oh oui je me suis très bien
adapté l'aviation parce que j'aime bien
les avions
l'époque des grandes épopées et des
s'enthousiasme planétaire est terminée
commence celle de l'astronautique
opérationnelle celle du service et de
l'efficacité
derrière l'astronaute c'est toute une
armée d'ouvriers de chercheurs
d'ingénieurs de techniciens tous les
vainqueurs de la lune qui doivent se
reconvertit ils ont tourné la page
pour avoir trop bien rempli leur
impossible mission ils doivent tout
recommencer pourtant la route fut longue
qui mena deux américains jusqu'à la mer
de la tranquillité
quand en 1961 le programme apollo fut
lancée par le président kennedy
l'astronautique américaine vivait des
heures héroïque celle des premiers vols
humains des folles mercury
elle était surclassé ridiculisé par sa
rivale soviétique le 5 mai 1961 alors qu
alan shepard gagné sa fusée redstone
pour faire un simple saut de puce dans
l'espace youri gagarine lui avait déjà
tourné autour de la terre et préparait
une tournée triomphale dans le monde
entier
[Musique]
avec des moyens dérisoires les
américains accomplissent des prodiges
alors que les soviétiques sur de leurs
techniques regret c'est avec une
insolente réussite
[Musique]
le 13 septembre 1961 quand john glenn
prend la route de l'espace il en est à
sa onzième tentative de lancement par
dix fois il a dû quitter sa cabine sans
avoir décollé à cause d'incidents
techniques
[Musique]
en dépit de ce magnifique succès
l'amérique semble définitivement
surpassé par l'ours dans l'exploration
de l'espace pour les américains et pour
le monde c'est une défaite majeure
incompréhensible en réalité les russes
sont longuement préparés durant les
années 50
les américains eux n'ont rien fait
l'espace ce n'est pas une affaire
commerciale comme les autres et le
système industriel américain s'en est
désintéressé le président kennedy
entreprend de réagir à cette industrie
qui ne peut réaliser le possible il
demande l'impossible la lune avant même
qu'elle ait maîtriser des techniques
spatiales avant qu'elle ait réalisé des
stations orbitales autour de la terre
l'astronautique américaine se lance dans
l'aventuré lunaire
ce n'est pas une nécessité logique c'est
une nécessité historique
[Musique]
à l'époque c'est un objectif légendaire
est inaccessible un rêve irréalisable
on ne sait rien notre satellite on ne
sait même pas s'il est possible de
marcher dessus l'astronautique lunaire
est au point zéro dans les bureaux
d'études
on dresse des plantes voyage pour
décrocher la lune comme pour gagner les
guerres l'amérique paris sur son
industrie tout le système industriel et
mobiliser les grands d'abord dans sa
mairie can't win douglas grumman general
electric ibm mais également 20000 firme
de moindre importance
quatre cent mille personnes travaillent
et il en coûte 125 milliards de francs
actuels pour arriver sur la lune
il faut tout inventer de la fusée au
moindre circuits électroniques de
l'ordinateur géant à la calculatrice
miniaturisés
le travail est réparti en cinq mille
tâches différentes à coordonner 7
millions de pièces détachées sont à
inventer
[Musique]
une obsession la fiabilité en 1961 les
échecs sont nombreux
on recherche les causes on améliore car
il ne peut pas y avoir des chèques sur
la route de la lune on torture le
matériel de toutes les façons pour en
vérifier la solidité c'est la guerre
contre le hasard commence alors la
construction de gigantesques usines ont
été édifiés aux quatre coins du
continent
maintenant le projet prend corps le
président kennedy a exigé la lune avant
70 et pour tenir ces délais ont
spécialistes le matériel le vaisseau
apollo le lem seront des pur-sang
lunaire le matériel d'une mission en
toute chose il faut prendre les
solutions immédiatement réalisable même
si elles sont chères ou compliqué
[Musique]
à la nouvelle orléans se construit le
grand paquebot lunaire le premier étage
de la saturn 5
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui on ne construit plus de
saturn 5
[Applaudissements]
car la fusée elle aussi était un engin
spécialisé
[Musique]
tout juste suffisante pour apollo trop
grosse pour les expériences autour de la
terre
à ce prix le projet progresse dans les
délais la préparation est aussi
épuisante pour les ingénieurs que pour
les astronautes
en 1966 le vaisseau apollo a déjà subi
vingt mille modifications chaque partie
est un monstre de complexité on se perd
dans les kilomètres de câbles du lait
mais du vaisseau spatial c'est à terre
que ce cahier la bataille que se
trouvent les plus grands risques
si neil armstrong avait dû se tuer sur
la route de la ligne il serait mort le 5
mai 1968 durant cette répétition
[Musique]
à cap kennedy on édifie un gigantesque
port lunaire le centre en élevé à b le
plus grand bâtiment du monde
la cathédrale de l'espace il est conçu
pour l'assemblage simultanée de quatre
saturn 5
ainsi pourra-t-on faire aisément un tir
lunaire tous les trois mois
on construit également plusieurs points
de tirs plusieurs salles de contrôle
pour des expéditions groupe et dans
l'avenir
tout est conçu prône ambitieux programme
lunaire dans les années 70 80
pari tenu les hommes et le matériel
tout est prêt dans les délais la grande
astronautique va commencer
[Musique]
pour les bureaux d'études apollo
appartient déjà au passé et ils font des
rêves grandioses pour l'avenir
le programme apollo et ses petites
excursions lunaire ne représente qu'une
première étape
[Musique]
au delà seront construites de
gigantesque station interplanétaire et
la cabine apollo ne sera plus qu'une
modeste navette entre la terre et
l'espace dans les années 70 se
développera l'exploration lunaire avec
des sortes de leyme géants et des
structures gonflables vers 90 enfouis
dans le sol
la maîtrise de la propulsion nucléaire
permettra de raccourcir considérablement
les voyages spatiaux alors vers la fin
des années 70 on concentrera tous les
efforts sur le pwa yaz maxi un grand
voyage pourrait être entrepris le 2
novembre 1980 avait calculé les experts
on a semblerait en orbite un gigantesque
vaisseau nucléaires pesant des centaines
de tonnes et l'on partirai pour un
voyage de plus de deux ans
[Musique]
où
un rêve certes mais parfaitement
réalisable car tous les problèmes
techniques qui ont été maîtrisés durant
le programme apollo
il suffirait de quelques années de
travail et de quelques dizaines de
milliards de dollars
sur le plan médical le voyage a été
préparé dans les stations orbitales où
l'on a fait ces journées des astronautes
durant plus d'un an
après neuf mois de voyage le vaisseau
arrive dans la banlieue de mars
il se retourne afin d'utiliser sa fusée
nucléaire comme frein le 9 août 1982 il
se satellise après quelques jours en
orbite martienne le compartiment
d'atterrissage va se détacher les
vaisseaux mères
[Musique]
c'est un engin qui pèsent des dizaines
de tonnes et porte un équipage de six
hommes durante un mois les astronomes se
livre à une exploration complète grâce à
leur véhicule ils vont visiter la grande
province équatoriale en particulier
puis c'est le retour selon la technique
apollo du rendez vous orbital
[Musique]
mais tout ici est dix fois plus gros
émile voit plus loin
[Musique]
après 81 jours passés en orbite
martienne c'est le départ vers la terre
il est prévu durant ce retour de faire
un crochet du côté de vénus
les
[Musique]
l'arrivée sur terre pourrait se faire
selon des techniques de type à poules ou
améliorés
[Musique]
ainsi rêve ingénieurs ces industriels
l'opération apollo a été leur université
de l'espace ils s'en sont sortis avec la
mention très bien
et désormais c'est tout le système
solaire qui est à portée de leurs
techniques ils veulent aller plus loin
car la nouvelle frontière
c'est l'infini
[Musique]
mais chemin faisant ils sont dédaigné
une planète la planète bleue la planète
vivante
la terre c'est elle qui aurait dû
normalement constitué le premier
objectif de l'astronautique s'il n'y
avait pas eu ce défi soviétique à
relever car l'espace et la position
idéale pour explorer notre planète comme
le montrent ces photos du satellite
ats non pas l'espace loin d'un lunaire
ou martien l'espace proche des orbites
terrestres ses sept astronautes hic au
service des hommes 7 astronautique
opérationnelle qui devient l'objectif
prioritaire mais le matériel apollo est
conçu pour l'astronautique lunaire il
est coûteux difficile à mettre en oeuvre
on conçoit une nouvelle génération
d'engins spatiaux la navette
[Musique]
c'est un projet ambitieux dations s'user
décollant à la verticale mais
atterrissant à l'horizontale comme un
simple avions un premier étage le
booster remporte le second sur son dos
jusqu'à 60 km d'altitude puis les deux
engins se séparent le booster redescend
vers la terre et l'orbiteur allumé ses
moteurs est monté vers l'orbité
terrestre
[Musique]
grâce à cette technique le coût des vols
spatiaux devrait être réduit
considérablement alors se mettrait en
place des liaisons régulières terre
espaces
[Musique]
l'orbiteur atteint la station spatiale
permanente
ils assurent les relèves d'équipage
apporte le ravitaillement
désormais il n'y a plus d'astronautes
seulement des pilotes professionnels et
des passagers ceux-ci chercheurs
techniciens ingénieurs travaillent en
orbite terrestre
ils font de la météorologie des
télécommunications de l'écologie de la
géologie
[Musique]
ainsi l'astronautique ce serait
banaliser à l'égal de l'aviation et il
n'en coûterait que la moitié du
programme apollo
[Musique]
mais l'amérique a bien changé depuis
qu'elle a décroché la lune elle voulait
prouver que son retard initial n'était
qu'un accident
elle a si bien réussi qu'elle n'a plus
rien à prouver et ce en revanche elle
découvre de nombreux problèmes terrestre
qui mobilise toute son attention
pollution délinquance pauvreté drogue
urbanisation le public américain
toujours été très divisé sur le
programme apollo
il est très réticent sur le programme
post un polo le congrès rogne
progressivement les crédits de la nasa
de 5 milliards de dollars on passe à
trois ce n'est pas assez pour le voyage
martien pas assez pour les bases
lunaires même pas suffisant pour la
navette
on se rabat sur une demi navette un
engin hybride dont le premier étage sera
formé par trois fusées contentera de
récupérer et le second seul et tente une
véritable navette récupérables dans
l'industrie spatiale c'est la
démobilisation les effectifs passent de
quatre cent mille hommes à 200000 chez
grumman près de new york
on a fabriqué le lem on espérait faire
la navette spatiale
maintenant il faut se reconvertir dans
cette grande salle qui vit naître le lem
on a repoussé les glorieux vestiges du
passé
une autre activité a pris la place
beaucoup sont encore sans travail
beaucoup ont eu à vendre leur maison et
à se déplacer dans d'autres endroits du
pays
c'est une c'est une tragédie économique
pour les individus surtout encore plus
que pour les compagnies parce que les
compagnies on parle de projet en général
nous avons une demi-douzaine de
deux types d'avions différents peut-être
en fabrication et ça nous permet de
de jouer avec les
[Musique]
avec le personnel nous mettant plus de
personnel sur un autre projet
on divise le personnel qui était utilisé
sur la navette spatiale entre les autres
projets on a très peu de gens à mettre à
la porte dans le sens malgré la perte de
ce contrat qui est très important
[Musique]
nous n'avons quand même bien la porte
qu'une partie de nos personnels notre
plus grande partie seulement une petite
partie
comme toujours le dynamisme de
l'américain a repris le dessus
la déception surmonter on se lance dans
une autre fois ils sont faits des
vaisseaux spatiaux
ils font des avions et la vie continue
[Musique]
l'astronautique américaine elle aussi
continue non plus l'astronautique
héroïque et légendaire de la course est
la lune mais une astronautique soucieuse
d'efficacité et de rentabilité qui
cherche à créer de nouveaux services
pour les hommes afin d'imposer sa
nécessité
apollo se termine on passe du rêve à la
réalité au réalisme eux mêmes mais le
rêve des années 60 ne faisait jamais
qu'anticipé sur les réalités du 21e
siècle
[Musique]